you're honor calling people versus Ethan
Crowley case number
2022-279-506 thank you good morning
appearances for the record
McDonald's
thank you Marquis for the people good
morning Runner Paulette Michelle Lofton
on behalf of beef and crumbly good
morning your honor Amy have family
good morning Generations
thank you and good morning to our
Council today theme time sets for a
pre-trial this morning how would you all
like to proceed
judges my understanding that the
defendant is going to plead guilt into
all 24 pounds thank you that is uh our
understanding as well your honor first
uh we filed a notice asserting the
defense of insanity on January 27th of
2022 at this time we are withdrawing
that notice and we'll be proceeding with
a guilty plea thank you and I will let
all Council know you may remove your
mask if you're comfortable thank you my
client has completed a pool for me I
approach your clerk you may just for the
record we've also executed a written
statement of DLP believe for the court
thank you
thank you with that being said is there
anything else we need to address before
I take your clients plea Mrs Lofton here
um I would ask the court to inquire of
Miss McKelvey as the lgal if she had
time to meet with Mr crumbly and what
the decision should be thank you Mr
Kilby good morning
after
um just locked in a nice folks that this
was going to take place today I went to
see him into jail on Thursday we did
send an appreciable time discussions I
believe she I believe as his lawyer
Guardian of Life and he does understand
what this process is what his intent is
to do today and I believe and I know
that was part of the pleat Forum that he
is doing this really voluntarily in the
morning so I
something he desires to do today thank
you with that being said anything else
from the people thank you Mr crumble if
you could please just post the podium
please raise your right hand under
penalty of perjury do you swear or earn
that the statements you're about to make
will be the truth thank you you put your
hand down what is your name
Mr crumbly how old are you 16 years old
can you read write and understand the
English language yes sir can you hear
and understand me the prosecutor as well
as your attorney
are you satisfied with the advice your
attorney is giving you and you also have
been appointed
um another court appointed attorney as
well as a legal guardian ad litem did
you have an opportunity to speak to your
legal guardian ad litem
and having spoken to your legal guardian
ad litem are you still prepared to
perceive this morning yes sir and you're
comfortable with proceeding yes sir you
understand that you have the right to
have an assistance of an attorney
throughout all proceedings and if you
cannot afford an attorney the court
would appoint one for you yes sir you
understand that you will be pleading
guilty to count one terrorism causing
death that is a felony where you face up
to life without parole or a minimum
sentence of 25 to 40 years and a maximum
sentence of at least 60 years you may
have to reimburse the government for
expenses incurred from the violation
you're also charged in count two first
degree premeditated murder
that is a felony where you face up to
life without parole or a minimum of 25
to 40 years and a maximum symptoms of at
least 60 years you're charging count
three with first degree premeditated
murder that is a felony where you face
up to life without parole or a minimal
sentence of 25 to 40 years and a maximum
sentence of at least 60 years you're
charged in count four with first-degree
murder that is a felony where you face
up to life without parole or a minimum
of sentence of 25 to 40 years and a
maximum sentence of at least 60 years
you're charged in count five with
homicide first degree murder that is a
felony where you face up to life without
parole or a minimum sentence of 25 to 40
years and a maximum census of at least
60 years you're charging count six with
the assault with intent to murder that
is a felony where you face up to life or
any number of years you're charging
counts seven with assault with intent to
murder that is a felony where you face
up to life or any number of years you're
charging counts eight with assault with
intent to murder that is a felony where
you face up to life or any number of
years
you're charged in count nine with the
salt with intent to murder that is a
felony where you face up to life or any
number of years in prison you're
charging count 10 with the salt with
intent to murder
that doesn't kill any reface up to life
or any number of years with the Michigan
Department of Corrections
you're charged to count 11 with assault
with intent to murder that is a felony
where you face up to life or any number
of years again with the Michigan
Department of Corrections you're
charging count 12 with the salt with
intent to murder that is a felony where
you face up the light or any number of
years with the Michigan Department of
Corrections you're charged with count 13
possession of a firearm in the
commission of a felony I will note for
the record that your charging counts 13
through
24 all being felony firearm offenses
counts 13 through 24 you face two years
consecutively with and preceding any
term of imprisonment imposed for the
felony or attempted felony conviction
you understand the maximum possible
penalties you face here yes sir you
understand that the maximum possible
Affinity based here on the underlying
offenses is up to life in prison
and that would be life in prison without
parole you understand that
Mr Keith is there a plea agreement thank
you
sir did you have an opportunity to
review people's exhibit number one with
your attorneys
and this is the platform that covers all
of your rights sir yes sir and did you
have an opportunity to sign this form
yes thank you and this form goes over
all of your rights is that correct I'm
going to cover your rights with you here
in court
so if you're please accept it you will
not have a trial of any kind and you'll
be given up the following rights the
right to be Tried by a jury and
throughout the trial the right to be
Presumed Innocent unless the prosecutor
proves your guilt Beyond reasonable
doubt you'll be given up the right to
have witnesses against your period of
the trial and to question Witnesses
against you you'll also be given up the
right to have the court order any
Witnesses you have to appear to trial
and you will be given up your right to
remain silent during the trial and the
right to not have that silence use
against you during the trial on the
other hand you could testify at trial if
you wanted to testify if you're please
accept it then you'll be given up and
claimed that The Plea was a result of
promises or threats that were not
disclosed on the record or that The Plea
was not of your own choice additionally
if you're please accept it you may be
giving up the right to appeal issues
that be otherwise appealable if you were
convicted at trial any appeal from
conviction a sentence pursuant to this
plea will be by application for leave to
appeal and not buy right a plea means
you have a conviction that may be used
against you in the future if you're on
probation or parole these police could
affect your status you understand that
were you born in the United States yes
sir I do have to advise you that if you
were not born in the United States this
is plea could affect your immigration
status sir has anyone promised anything
where made threats that has not been
stated on the record is it your own
choice to plead guilty yes sir do you
need any more time to talk to your
attorneys about any of your rights
no sir and I will allow the prosecutor
to conduct the wadir however I will ask
you sir did these offenses occur only
about November 30th 2021 in Oakland
County yes sir what city or Township
long term thank you people thank you
sir on that date November 30th 2021 in
Oakland County Michigan did you bring a
nine millimeter six hour handgun in 50
rounds of nine million nine millimeter
ammunition with you to the Oxford High
School
did you keep the gun ammunition in your
backpack with you that day
is it true that approximately 12 49 pm
on a date you entered a boy's bathroom
in the Oxford High School
can you keep your voice up for me
is it true that while inside the boy's
bathroom in the stall of the bathroom
you remove the handgun from your
backpack yes is it true that you ensured
that the handgun was loaded yes is it
true that you exited to the bathroom
approximately 12 51 pm on November the
30th 2021. yes is it true that when you
exited the bathroom you begin shooting
at students and staff members of the
Oxford High School yes judge for the
specific actual basis I'm going to do
accounts two through five and then count
one please
regarding count two first degree murder
this is true in November the 30th 2021
while you were in Oxford County of
Oakland you deliberately with the intent
to kill and with premeditation use a
nine millimeter handgun and shoot and
kill Miss Madison Baldwin
yes is it true on November the 30th 2021
while you were in Oxford County of
Oakland you did deliberately with the
intent to kill and with premeditation
use a nine millimeter handgun and shoot
and kill Mr Tate Meyer
through November the 30th 2021 while
you're in Oxford County of Oakland you
deliberately with the intent to kill and
with premeditation did use a nine
millimeter handgun and shoot and kill
this Hana St Julian
yes is it true November the 30th 2021
while you were in Oxford County of
Oakland you did deliberately with the
intent to kill and premeditation use a
nine millimeter handgun to shoot and
kill Mr Justin chilling
did you repeat your answer sir yes thank
you is it true that on November the 30th
2021 when you committed the crimes of
first degree premeditated the murder in
Oxford County of Oakland that you acted
knowingly willfully deliberately meaning
you consider the pros and cons of your
actions then you made the decision
after substantial reflection to commit
first degree premeditated murder
yes is it true that you knew or had
reason to know that your choices on
November the 30th 2021 and committing
these crimes would cause a substantial
likelihood of death or Serious injury
yes is it true when he committed these
crimes you intended to put students and
teachers in fear and you intended to
cause Panic among the Oxford High School
community
yes
is it true that your actions on November
30th 2021 caused the deaths of Madison
Baldwin Samir Anna St Juliana and Justin
Schilling yes
regarding count six to prove that on
November the 30th 2021 we assaulted Miss
TV Archer by shooting her with a nine
millimeter handgun it was your intention
to kill her
yes count seven is it true that November
the 30th 2021 you assaulted Mr John
ashuto by shooting him with a nine
millimeter handgun and was your
intention to kill him
yes down Eight Is it true that on
November the 30th 2021 you assaulted
Miss Molly Darnell by shooting her with
a nine millimeter handgun it was your
intention to kill her yes
our ninth is it true that in November
the 30th 2021 consulted Miss Riley Franz
by shooting her with a nine millimeter
handgun it was their intention to kill
her yeah
about 10. is it true that on November
the 30th 2021 do South and Mr Elijah
Mueller by shooting him with a nine
millimeter handgun and was your
intention to kill him
yes
2011. is it true that in November 30th
2021 you assaulted
uh
Miss Carly Osage with the intent to
commit the crime of murder in Missouri
by shooting her with a nine millimeter
handgun it was near intention to kill
her yes
that's well is it true that November
30th 2021
the assaulted Mr Aiden Watson uh
shooting him with a nine millimeter
handgun lose your attention to kill him
yes
recounts 13 through 24. judge I'm going
to take the actual basis all at once
these are all the felony firearm crimes
is it true on November 30th 2021 that
all crimes were carried out while you
possessed and used that nine millimeter
handgun
yes is it true that the firearm that you
use in November the 30th was purchased
on November the 26 2021 by your father
James crumbling
yes is it true that you asked him to buy
the firearm
Jesus Is it true that you gave him your
own money to buy that buyer yes
is it true that you picked that gun out
to buy
yes
is it true that November 30th 2021
that nine millimeter handgun that she
used in Oxford High School was not kept
any safe or lock container
is it true about November the 30th 2021
when you obtain the firearm it was not
kept in a locked container or a safe yes
it was not locked people are satisfied
thank you the court adopts the people's
lives here as its own with that being
said defense satisfied as well thank you
does the prosecutor defense attorney
agree that the court has complied with
sub rules but you can d yes
thank you and if I haven't stated it
based upon that what year I do believe
there's sufficient factual basis support
the convictions in counts one through
24. with that being said is either
prosecutor or defense attorney aware of
any promises threats or inducements
other notes close on the recorder thank
you the court buys plea to be voluntary
understanding and accurately given and I
accept the plea the court will set this
matter for a tentative Miller hearing on
February 9 2023 at 9 00 a.m that will be
in person here in my courtroom as
councilors aware we must continue to
conduct a review hearing every 30 days
because the dependent is a minor at the
Oakland County Jail as such the court
will conduct a review Hearing in this
matter on November 29th 2022 at 9 00 a.m
via Zoom with that being said is there
anything else for the record this
morning I did want to know for the
record that paragraph two of her
statement of guilty plea does indicate
that to the extent it ever becomes
necessary the parties do do agree to
supplement today's record with all case
reports all evidence submitted to this
court during the Juvenile Justice and
delinquency prevention hearings that
occurred February 22nd March 24th April
21st May 19th June 23rd July 22nd August
25th September 22nd and October the 20th
thank you so noted anything else for the
record
just just so the record is clear the
tenant of Miller hearing date is
February the 9th we'll have a sentencing
hearing after that date is that correct
that is correct the court will set it
for sentencing after I have conducted
the Miller hearing to give myself an
opportunity to make a decision about the
Miller hearing as well as to allow
Council to supplement any record that
they need to supplement
we have a lot of victims and important
to be a lot of Victims Watching and just
to put on the record that they will have
an opportunity to make a statement to
the courtroom absolutely thank you thank
you with that being said anything else
no Josh thank you thank you all right
thank you deputies you may take the
minute thank you if everyone in Portland
could please be seated
just
ice
thank you with that being said the court
is going to stand in recess all right